ist putin witzig also ich kann sagen
unser präsident hat durchaus einen sinn
für humor gut und wird das merkel
treffen
[Musik]
zunächst einmal ganz wichtige frage wir
sind ja hier in der in der botschaft
sind wir hier schon auf russischem boden
also ist das quasi wie russland ja das
stimmt
sie sind wirklich hier buchstäblich
sogar dem russischen boden dann darf ich
sie runter bringen jetzt eben die
kritischen fragen herausstreichen
[Applaus]
besser ich glaube das kann so bleiben
russland ist ein wichtiger bestandteil
europas
ohne russland geht es in europa nicht
wer hat das gesagt wer weiß dass die
klasse also das braucht das kann jeder
sagen das ist tatsache
kommen wir zur nächsten frage russland
sagt es gibt keine russischen soldaten
die in der ukraine kämpfen wenn
überhaupt sein dass soldaten die da ich
sagte zitat urlaub machten jetzt meine
frage in welchen ländern werden
russische soldaten demnächst urlaub
machen dann sagen dass wenn die ukraine
es keine reguläre russen streitkräfte
gibt was die freiwilligen an betrifft
können wir dazu nicht sagen weil es gibt
auch freiwillige aus deutschland in
syrien stehen so das muss man auch
revidieren auch geht versuchen wir es
einfach mal plastisch darzustellen also
nehmen wir an sie würden jetzt mal die
rolle von putin spielen und ich spiele
die von angela merkel
ich sitze dann da und sage vladimir
bitte tut mir den gefallen und zieh dich
zurück aus der ukraine liebe liebe
angela ich kann nur sagen wir sind nicht
in der ukraine
also wenn
ich kann nicht von ungefähr weil die
bevölkerung dort das bewusst hat ist
putin witzig also ich kann sagen unser
präsident hat durchaus einen sinn für
humor
gut nur dass ich mit merkel treffen gibt
es etwas was ihnen an putin überhaupt
nicht gefällt was ihn richtig auf den
sack geht also diese frage müssen sind
nicht dann einen mitarbeiter der
botschaft stellen wir diese fragen
beantworten muss oder darf beides
herzlich danken für das gespräch und
auch noch mal auf unserer seite
herzlichen glückwunsch dass die krim
angeht und damit gebe ich zurück so
oliver p
[Applaus]
[Musik]